contrary to popular opinion frogs aren't
just selective eaters feasting only on
flies take the bullfrog for example
Bailey of spiders
[Music]
rodents snakes fish and just about
anything else that passes in front of
them but how do they manage to be such
eating machines bullfrogs don't have big
claws sharp beats or fangs yet they
overcome pincers poisons and spicy
stingers great outdoors ready to swallow
just about anything
they've been known to swim 20 feet to
shore and have an additional 15 to 20
grab a meal turn a rolling and hop back
into the pond they've even been known to
stalk it's like a lion on the prowl
eating them winged feet and all and they
don't stop at their feathered friends
they'll even eat each other
a small bullfrog that doesn't watch its
step can easily become food for a bigger
frog they are quite cannibalistic a
young bullfrog must quickly learn one
simple froggy back eat whatever it wants
just don't end up on someone else's menu